[Music]
in parking lot pursued news hey will Oh
submitted by like an omen nothing like a
doormat a pregnant woman ran her car
into a purse thief but is now facing
charges herself Oh Rafi makes women
crazy they shouldn't be out the house
what huh one other princess excuse me
Rafi say to my face kind of crazy to me
yeah Wow what because just pregnant
you're crazy what have I done you just
say all kind of crazy [ __ ] like oh you
look nice today
purple almost all going crazy behind the
wheel she's gotta run people over like
then this girl like you some good don't
she ran a jumper see right I get ya but
that's a salt cake this attempted murder
assault with a deadly weapon that's
helping justice that's the part that I
missed
she's a crime fighter yeah okay it's not
the pregnancy the pregnancy made her
like protective nurturing science just
did an article about a did that [ __ ]
was running away from the police and the
person ran the car that was running away
from the police
oh yeah yeah and they were like oh
what's the [ __ ] difference
I was quite a car Mimi and I'll give a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] purse they do
deserve to get your knees chopped
I give the pregnant woman props because
what I do and I don't I give her props
because in her state she was willing to
wear this year pregnancy what
fundamental Alabama pregnancy yes Oh in
her state of Alabama in her state of
Alabama princey she was willing to risk
herself and her baby to stop this person
yeah I don't like it because she put her
baby I saw that she don't give a [ __ ]
though that's how gangster she is was it
her purse that got stolen insurance oh
she does oh oh and they took it back
she's I'm teaching or not
she's only teaching our kid how by
Carter you know what ladies get all mad
nah they do what it is not hot oh oh oh
oh sure is a snack oh we met yeah there
you go yeah what'd y'all think though
cuz you coming over here talking all
that [ __ ]
anything circular not satisfied it's not
this it's [ __ ] Congress arrived where
every time we because like you gotta get
in this every time in my store I got the
same [ __ ] you tell me right now that
this [ __ ] was 99 cents and now it's a
dollar seven you people for trying to
rip me off there it is girls will make
really good boxers all day how do we did
I Michael Jackson mm-hmm
so this line her name is Christine this
takes place in North Carolina mm-hmm let
your [ __ ] neck away some of us have
people down no take a [ __ ] Buddha
handout and everything you know that'll
[ __ ] your buddha meditation han but it's
like this the way that your lips are
burning yeah
your back is all straight that's what
they always look at you with that side I
do crystal oh good at that you look like
something really wrong
I don't submit really look like they
turn away for some [ __ ] to go down
you'll see it they'll do that now look
around behind images what you looking
around for
[Laughter]
so Christine was saying that she spotted
this dude named Robert going through her
purse and then at that point is when he
decided to take off so they were in the
parking lot she ran after him prep is
five months pregnant all not huge five
months pregnant she ran after him and
she thought that she turned back around
she got into her cars putting her gear
she's just random so here we go I'm sure
you buy ran is at all there's a DPO
these are the mug shot Christine and
Robert and yes there's an issue that
like she does CrossFit she didn't do
anything wrong neck looks sick you
caring so it is a beauty oh quick video
smash that fool someone's just recording
the whole thing while they could zoom in
pretty well with the home Oh satisfying
slow-mo that [ __ ] yeah stop that [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah yeah that's dope dude she
should get a trophy
and it's not like she went all the way
through she hit a mission she's not dead
right now
perfect because in their state they
believe like in caring and if somebody
violates you you can bang bang boogie
what is that called the self-defense
allows the cats are laws all that stuff
we're at Carolina mmm-hmm Carolina they
have one of those you steal for me a
shoots you to death five months pregnant
man steals your purse what do you do
pregnant woman five months five if I
could do that in the safety of your own
car well she chased them and then she
had to get back in her car and drive out
would you have chased the person by
lines now
and what do you think about that Bart I
file is there then I'll just tackle the
[ __ ] out yeah if you would I think I
think you're asking what he thinks about
my what do you think about her response
is that a smart choice I understand
where she's coming from because she
wants to take care of the baby
yeah well my she's not a serial [ __ ] I'm
not going to be joining a fan club but
at least your child's [ __ ] well
protected but that lady her child a
lesson that most moms unable to teach
her child can't even [ __ ] open their
eyes yet write what they feel the vibe
he feels the courage and mom not the
fear it could feel the courage they
could feel the courage hormone instead
of the flight hormone you know how they
say if you play classical music the baby
can feel that [ __ ] when you're ready to
[ __ ] murder a [ __ ] because he
done stole your barcia's baby can feel
that too they like it to [ __ ] a bus back
instead of mama scared oh I'm scared to
know what actually sounds real though I
would be pissed
I'm probably a little scared but I'd be
like I'm doing this for you see sever
nothing so like mom alone I think in my
car I will be carrying a bazooka that
has the net and the balls in it
oh that's realistic but I'm sorry David
you carrying it when you said that
you're going to have one of those
weapons I just imagined it just when you
shoot it it shoots at you and somehow
you get wrapped in it yeah it's going to
be pointed this win it for you but then
it's going to be backwards interval poem
yeah and you're going to catch our wife
you guys have been watching a little bit
too much Austin Powers I am a human
being and I know how to read I haven't
watched Austin Powers the way you're
talking about it I just watch you in
life and I think that I will mess up
once and that's why I'll have a spare in
my trunk and then I will get the other
one out and I should be able to get him
eventually what I would like to do would
you be down a tag team let's rebel oh we
see that [ __ ]
so you drive and I hang out the outside
of the home with that and I put my arm
out like it's al and hopefully it
doesn't break but they'll be tight
because as you drive up to Bull Riders
ideas after that it would be so dope to
watch Mariel confront a man and knock
his ass
like I want to see her quite a girl yeah
like she's like walking by right and
that we're walking by it like let's say
a cafe as we're walking by a do goes
well stop [ __ ] and then I'm like yo but
she puts her hand on my chest bushes be
back I don't see that happening oh I
want to see that though and she's like
hold on say I'm not do well comes up so
she's so emotional and she still about
her beliefs or whatever that she would I
think the guy would say that and she
would forget that you're in the room and
just like charge mmm
I want to see you [ __ ] a dude or a girl
apparently my stuff dude you generated
so when are we awarding this lady with
the honor of trophy of dollar doctor
overruled I overruled the citizen speak
Becky sprinkled fairy dust overruled no
it went away right now
I'll see you near your kazoo - Louis
that's what happened bad things go away
me old yeah so she's facing charges for
assault with a deadly weapon that makes
sense and Roberts is charged with
breaking and entering a motor vehicle
and larceny oh she was putting maybe
taking the cart back and then he went
through the passenger instead of maybe
because they'll sort of report it so I
don't want to tell you guys something
Mandarin no I just think that she should
just maybe give me given the golden
handcuffs Award for something for those
four dominatrix if it's for citizens
that take it upon themselves for people
to catch those that [ __ ] prey upon
normal people she should gather a
payroll rights at least a month no it
could fold in handcuffs award yeah
okay you don't need a waste of taxpayers
dollars you just need to with Gordon you
just get [ __ ] a ghost everyone knows
that it's actually famous bill on the
inside and they spray-painted it or like
chocolate or something you know like
it's just gold foil you know everyone
knows
get back each other up all the [ __ ]
time I have your [ __ ] child and mean
your I could back me and we're gonna
look around it you were gonna be a
[ __ ] rammer I wouldn't consider it
backing up we just know the same [ __ ]
but here's a better question who came
first Joe or gia oh that's what [ __ ]
what's wrong with you [ __ ] loyalty
[ __ ] yeah I came first you met him after
that's not true we met you at the same
time at the bookstore
I know handy for you know but we met the
same time yes go get it back him are you
gonna be a rammer
I know specifically when they all
decided to go inside the bookstore to
talk to her
BAM and you're not a rammer what do you
mean BAM pack me off what the [ __ ] were
they going to the bookstore to talk to
you about they wanted to hit on me are
you gonna [ __ ] RAM or not and shut up
Ambar was the wingman oh and I was like
three guys is too intimidating i'ma wait
outside
oh you were there too yeah that was the
day you guys met I don't remember him
but I'm changing my last name
that's your amla's Jill ran with Jill
ráma rám list hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
what the who I other than that you know
it's like more videos are there bro
[Music]